the recent inflation that we have seen
will be temporary it's not something
that's endemic um i expect it to last
however for several more months and to
see
high annual rates of inflation through
the end of this year
oh there you go what she's not telling
you is that president biden is trying
his best to make sure
inflation isn't just a phase but the new
normal
the president is putting forward the
largest federal spending plan in history
a whopping 6 trillion dollars of course
you won't see any of that money
in fact you'll be made poorer under
biden's proposal trump's tax cuts for
low and middle income americans
will be allowed to expire in 2025
if these cuts aren't replaced or
extended biden would be breaking his
promise
to not raise taxes on anyone making less
than 400 thousand dollars a year
joining us now is dr ben carson former
hud secretary
and the founder of the american
cornerstone institute dr carson thank
you for joining me tonight
i i think that none of us are surprised
that joe biden is breaking a promise i
think many of the things that are said
are like from a grab bag just to perhaps
get elected
uh this this clearly can be tragic
if we continue to allow it uh to unfold
what is your take on this sir
well the sad part to me you know having
spent you know my entire professional
career
as a pediatric neurosurgeon and
concerned about the welfare of children
is seeing what we are doing to their
future
these things cannot done be done without
consequences
and it was thomas jefferson who said it
is
immoral to steal from future generations
it's exactly what we're doing
in creating amounts of amazing debt that
somebody's going to have to deal with
not only that but even currently you
look at the
impact of flooding the system with money
but not having the equivalent abundance
of services and goods that automatically
creates inflation as milton friedman
eloquently
talked about and we are it's almost as
if we've we've read all the books and we
said yes
we too want to have the same problems
that argentina had and that venezuela
had
and that all the countries who did the
same thing had
somehow we're going to be different i
don't think we're going to be different
and
we're smart enough we should be i think
the average american person
knows that we are creating a monstrous
problem for ourselves
well and sir we we've we lived through
the carter years
right we've seen a lot of different
presidencies we've seen
that with what president trump did that
this is not normal
that leadership matters that standards
can be set
and it is very strange sir for adult
people men and women
joe biden's been in office for almost 50
years now for them to suggest things
that we know historically there is not
one successful effort
to implement this that the spending of
money it's almost like it's monopoly
money at this point like it's water
that's correct and nowhere in the world
nowhere historically
has the big push to socialism work
it always seems good in the beginning
when you still have a pile
of money to deal with but
as margaret thatcher said it's great
until you run out of other people's
money
and and you will run out of other
people's money because first of all
people won't be making as much money but
also many very successful people
will take their money and go elsewhere
that's exactly what happened in france
some years ago
when they became wild with their taxes
and it's exactly what will happen to us
as well not to mention the fact that
you know we put a big stop sign
on the manufacturing and some of the
things that we're drawing people here
you know it's just going to have a
horrible consequence it's almost as
though
it's a horrible thing to even have to
consider that they
they want this to occur but we will have
to make sure they're not successful
uh dr carson thank you for being with us
tonight your insight's always terrific
thank you sir thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else